questions over islamophobia in the
conservative party run
wide and deep and right to the very top
boris johnson himself wants under
investigation over his comments
about muslim women an issue i put to him
during his leadership campaign in 2019.
you brought shame on your party when you
described veiled muslim women
as letter boxes and bank robbers
well beth i i'm i'm i'm delighted that
um many of my former colleagues uh
seem to descend from from from that view
but for all those jeers today an
independent inquiry found the party does
have a problem
and the pm himself is partly to blame
the 50-page report found there is
evidence of anti-muslim sentiment at
local association
and individual levels high-profile
incidents such as remarks made during
lord goldsmith's mayoral campaign
and pm boris johnson's comments on
muslim women
give the impression to many that the
party and its leadership are insensitive
to muslim communities but for this
former party chair
the report falls short you still think
that the conservative party is
institutionally racist despite the
findings in this report the report
concludes that from the top
from the prime minister at one level to
local associations at the bottom
there is an attitude issue and a problem
and a behavior
issue in terms of islamophobia and beth
you know the way i see it if it looks
like institutional racism
feels like institutional racism fits the
definition of institutional racism
then i'm afraid it is institutional
racism is boris johnson part of the
problem here
i think boris accepts that he is part of
the problem and that he got it wrong
in the past and as he says himself that
words that he used and thought he could
get away with a journalist and not the
words that would suit
a prime minister beth this has been a
six-year campaign
it's been a lonely campaign it's been a
hurtful campaign
it's been difficult to challenge friends
and colleagues
and certainly i will be referring the
party to the equalities and human rights
commission
and i will ask it to investigate where i
see a fundamental flaws
in this report the current co-party
chair with an
apology and promise of reform the prime
minister has been cleared that
you know in in the interview which he
did with professor singh
to say that you know he was sorry if he
had caused any offence to anyone
in through his comments as a party we
have a
zero tolerance approach to all forms of
discrimination
this report does make for uncomfortable
reading
and we've got work to do remarks mr
johnson made before he was the resident
here
have hurt the muslim community and
damaged his party
the issue of islamophobia goes right to
his
door and for many in the muslim
community this matter is still
not closed beth rigby sky news
westminster